Basile banabre vous co présidez le
groupe de travail sur le cadre mondial
vous gérez le processus de négociation
vous avez déposé un premier jet donc cet
été on voit qu'il y a une bonne partie
du texte qui est entre crochet où est-ce
qu'on en est dans ce processus de
négociation c'est un processus qui a été
long on a été interrompu à mi-course par
le covid comme tout le monde et il a
fallu repartir la machine en janvier on
va commencer une cinquième et dernière
séance de négociation avant la Coop où
on espère pour voir encore une fois
diminuer le nombre de crochets de d'un
bon nom on va probablement en enlever
encore la moitié
les enjeux sont maintenant claires une
image je dirais qu'on a maintenant sur
la table tous les blocs de Lego qui sont
nécessaires et notre succès dépend de la
volonté des négociateurs de travailler
ensemble pour assembler ces blocs de
Lego dans un cadre mondial qui nous
permettra d'aller de l'avant quand on
regarde le texte est-ce qu'il y a des
éléments qui sont qui vont être pour
vous les plus
difficiles ou les plus chaudement
discutés il y a un élément qui qui est
extrêmement visible dans les
négociations c'est la protection et la
conservation du territoire le fameux 30
par 30 alors il y a une coalition
formidable autour de cet enjeu là et
c'est une bonne chose ce que nous
cherchons c'est un engagement équivalent
envers les quatre autres causes de la
biodiversité qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
pour l'exploitation qui n'en durable
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour les
espèces envahissantes qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire pour la pollution et finalement le
grand enjeu des changements climatiques
alors quels vont être les discussions
quel chiffre allons nous mettre sur
sur ces anges là ça ça va être
extrêmement important
quels sont les Peseux de ce texte là
maintenant ce qu'on doit avoir
maintenant c'est un cadre qui est
équilibré et qui donne tout autant des
progrès du côté de la conservation de la
nature mais aussi de la du bien-être des
populations et de la façon dont ces
populations pourront se développer d'une
manière juste parmi nous il est clair
que dans de nombreux pays développés en
particulier en Europe on a bénéficié de
la nature depuis des générations pour
créer un bien-être social et une
richesse
il serait très difficile de ne pas
permettre à certains pays un
développement de ne pas faire la même
chemin alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à naviguer au travers de ça
trouver des solutions gagner en gagnant
qui nous permettent de voir un
développement durable et sain et juste
qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour en arriver à
un accord ambitieux au terme de ces
négociations à Montréal
bien malin qui pourrait le dire
aujourd'hui si on arrive à faire un
accord qui nous permet de savoir quel
progrès on fait au cours des 8
prochaines années ça sera déjà un grand
pas et ça nous permet ça permettra à
ceux qui viendront après nous de
corriger le tirer votre espoir pour cet
accord-là je pense que les pays ont
l'ambition d'avoir un résultat positif
je n'ai entendu personne dire qu'il ne
voulait pas d'un accord ce qui est un
changement et avec du temps avec de la
bonne volonté de l'écoute et du
leadership de nos de nos ministres on va
avoir un accord positif rendez-vous le
20 décembre merci beaucoup